[Música]
Escocia sino también en gales y en
Irlanda del Norte Pues también lo que
ocurrió en ese momento Es que después de
estas proclamaciones las banderas una
vez más pues fueron ya puestas de nuevo
a mediasta esa era otra de las digamos
digamos
de la llegada pues del cortejo fúnebre
aquí a edimburgo precisamente Natalia
volviendo a esta tan esperada llegada
del cortejo fúnebre contanos cómo está
el ambiente sigue llegando gente
sí muchísima muchísima gente ya nosotros
vamos a mostrarles unas imágenes luego
pero sí ya aquí en el casco antiguo de
edimburgo Pues hay muchísima gente que
ya llegó desde antes incluso
precisamente porque iban a esperar la
proclamación muchos también quieren
tener un buen puesto para poder ver el
paso del cortejo fúnebre de poder darle
pues está despedida a su a su reina
hemos visto también varios buses que
están ya llevando a los diferentes
Towers que van a estar a lo largo de
todo el recorrido también pues ayudando
con la coordinación y con la seguridad
Cuántas personas esperan es que son
miles y de hecho aquí donde estoy que
estos son los digamos los jardines
pues mucha gente está precisamente
viendo cómo puede ir sobre todo pues más
del lado de hollywoodhouse ese es el
castillo o el Palacio donde va a estar
el féretro de la Reina Isabel o por unas
24 horas Así que la gente todavía
algunas la mayoría de las de las
arterias alrededor del casco urbano
están cerradas Así que el paso está
siendo un poquito complicado entonces
pues como les decía muchísima gente
justamente cuando ya pues este cortejo
debe pasar dentro de unos minutos por la
ciudad